[Music]
hi I'm Anna Kendrick and I'm Justin
Timberlake's solafeet poppy is the
happiest troll of all the trolls how do
you always on the bright side and
branches the opposite I don't do have
Fox slap it boss
nope little slappy make daddy happy fine
too slow oh snap this is the story about
happiness
topic how far some would go to get it
how far we went to get it back what's
your plan to rest or every want to make
it home safely so you're going to
scrapbook them to freedom solid burn
branch it's so wonderful to get to voice
these characters and I think music adds
so much to animation it just feels like
they belong together
the bergen's gather the trolls that
they've caught and it's the music that
rescues them Hewitt the
eyes don't be discouraged oh I realize
it's hard to take courage in a world
full of people you can lose sight of it
all the darkness inside you
can make you feel so small and I see
your true the creators of schwag invite
you on a musical adventure the keys one
voice can change the world happiness is
inside of all of us sometimes I just
need someone to help you find it
DreamWorks toys
come
beautiful now they can we hug find your
happy place
November 4th poppy is the leader of the
trolls and it's not her fault she's so
insanely happy